>>Teacher: That's incredible.
That's the best we've seen yet.
>>Narrator: Fourth and fifth
graders at Clear View Charter School
in Chula Vista, California, work
over a two way interactive
video connection
with scientists at
a local university.
Together they study insects
under an electron microscope.
>>Teacher: Okay, introduce
yourselves,
girls, get in closer, Tammy.
>>Narrator: This project provides a
hands on understanding of insects,
far beyond what is possible with
traditional classroom resources.
Today, students in Jim Dieckmann's
class collect more insects to examine
under the electron microscope.
>>Charles: With this insect
project that we're doing,
somebody could just tell us the parts
of an insect, but we go in depth
to see closer and learn by ourselves,
instead of somebody else telling us.
>>Student: Oh, what
kind of bug is that?
>>Jim: This project
that we've been working
on with insects is really an effort
to teach students, what is the life
of a scientist really about?
What is the scientific
process as well?
And that's what we're
attempting to do.
>>Albert: We're studying right
now the mouth parts, most of.
And see if the-- it c-- if the
difference of what they eat
and their mouth parts, the
[inaudible] like a beetle
that eats stuff that has to
crunch, so the mouth part,
it's like a little
cruncher, like this.
>>Charles: Its mandibles
are different than ours.
They're on the side of their mouth.
It's from here and they
chew this way, not this way.
They chew like this, not like this.
>>Howard: We have schools,
because we hope that some day,
when children have left schools,
that they will still be able
to use what it is that
they've learned.
And there is now a massive amount of
evidence from all realms of science,
that unless individuals take a
very active role in what it is
that they're studying, unless
they learn to ask questions,
to do things hands on to essentially
recreate things in their own mind
and then transform them as is
needed, the ideas just disappear.
>>Narrator: Charles and Albert
collected several specimens,
but the wasp they want so
much still eludes them.
And the class has only two days
before a scheduled online link
up with the electron microscope.
>>Jim: They're doing the collection.
They're doing the preparation.
They're doing research in order
to try to find out what they can
about this insect and then trying
to pose some kinds of questions
that could be answered
through direct observation
with this powerful tool that we have.
That's the electron
microscope itself.
>>Student: If you look just
with the little magnifier,
you can only see them
about fifteen max.
But with the electron
microscope, you can go as high
as seven hundred something
to see 'em.
And it's kinda interesting that
you can see all the hairs on him,
and you never thought he
had like little hairs.
>>Neil: So in one sense, you're
essentially asking the student
to be a researcher, whereas before
you might have thought the faculty's
doing research, the
students are learning.
Now, in effect, you're
saying to the students,
"Go out and do the research,
which is not bounded,
which is really limitless, and
keep generating the questions,
because as you find more and
more information out there,
you'll find that it
doesn't necessarily coincide
with your first idea.
You'll have to change your
idea, then you'll have to look
for more information to get
that into some kind of sync
with what you've been thinking."
Second of all, it becomes
very collaborative,
and that can be not
just among students.
It can be between you
and your teacher,
or it can be with people
in the outside world.
So once again, you're functioning
almost the way a faculty member
or an adult in any field
functions as a researcher.
>>Jim: All right.
I can see most people are
just continuing on there.
That's good, jumping around
sometimes a little bit.
>>You see the students
working around.
They're pretty much self
motivated and self directed,
so that it's not all teacher
supervised, teacher directed.
They take the responsibility,
and I think that's really
what becomes a real value
of this particular kind of learning.
>>James: It isn't enough to
just wait for it to trickle
down through scholars that
use here and write textbooks.
It's important to get these
resources directly in the hands
of young learners, who wouldn't
be able to use the reading rooms
of the Library of Congress,
but can use this material,
if we make it more
accessible and user friendly,
as we're trying to do all the time.
>>Narrator: To share their research,
Albert and Charles prepare
a multimedia report.
>>Computer: Wasps by
Albert and Charles.
>>Albert: On next-- to the next page.
>>Computer: Here are
the wasps mating.
>>Narrator: These interactive
multimedia technologies give students
a new way to express their ideas and
demonstrate what they've learned.
>>Albert: We have to make
up a text box for this one.
>>Charles: Text box.
>>Jim: Using multimedia, it's just a
tremendous amount of decision making
that has to be done by the students.
When they just simply look
at the quantity of resources
that are available for them to
make this particular report,
then they have to become
very discriminating
as to what pieces they need in order
to impart their particular message.
>>The content is extremely
important to me,
and that's the area where I push on.
That's what I do as a
teacher, to push the students
into finding more information,
to synthesizing that information,
to putting it in a presentable
form that's understandable to them,
and to the ultimate user.
And the components include
looking at the insects themselves
in the traditional ways that we
might, through text and pictures,
as well as other images of the
insects that they might find on CDs
or find via the internet
and download that way.
>>I'd try Alta Vista.
That'd be my suggestion too.
Okay?
>>Charles: Okay.
>>Albert: Four thousand.
>>Jim: Okay, you got four
thousand-- ooh, what's this?
>>Charles: That's how to get rid of--
>>Jim: What's that?
>>Charles: What do to with them.
>>Jim: It might be useful
for you to just save
that piece, to read offline, okay?
'Cause there's awful lot there.
Then you can just take it
off and read it later on.
Maybe there's one or two important
points there about controlling wasps
that would be important to you, okay?
>>Albert: To catch one.
>>Jim: How to catch
one, that might be it.
>>Kristina: If we were back in the
fifteen hundreds, sixteen hundreds,
and we were Gutenberg, inventing this
printing press, we'd be so delighted
that we'd be able to take
knowledge and distribute it,
and also preserve it for
different generations.
Imagine though, we're
standing at that same point now
where we're not limited
to just type on a page.
We can preserve ideas,
we can represent ideas
in a full component of ways.
We have images available,
we have sound available.
We have two way communication
available.
And that's where we're standing right
now, in terms of the capabilities.
How we're gonna use those is
the challenge at the moment.
>>Jim: All right, between
now and recess,
you have a very important job to do.
>>Narrator: Many educators
are seeking better ways
to evaluate student achievement,
so that the assessment
furthers the learning process.
>>Jim: Construct a rubric for the--
>>Narrator: Jim Dieckmann helps the
students create their own standards
or rubrics for assessing the
quality of their projects.
>>Jim: -- what would make
a good multimedia project.
What would be the best
multimedia presentation on insects?
What would it contain?
Thinking about content and
also thinking about technique,
the way in which it's put together.
You need to take one person who's
going to record the information.
>>Shirley: It is more difficult
to assess the learning that occurs
through this kind of project based
experience, that it is not going
to be assessable through fill
in the bubble kinds of tests,
that they're gonna have to be
much richer forms of assessment
that can really capture how much
more the students actually know.
>>Student: We can make buttons that
can jump to other pages, yeah, links.
>>Student: About how many?
>>Jim: In the multimedia project,
after the students have actually done
a little work with it and done some
of their research and started
to actually construct the
project itself, then we sit down
and we discuss, what is it
that would make the best
multimedia presentation?
That then is placed
in the students' hands
so they know what they're
working towards.
It's not like, "The teacher's
gonna give me a A, B or C,
but I don't know what I have
to do to get A, B or C."
So they have all of that up front
and I like to have the students help
me develop those particular rubrics,
'cause they're the ones
that are doing the work.
>>How about some of the other
tables sharing some information?
>>Student: It has to
be in your own words.
>>Jim: Ah, text in
own words; Desiree?
>>Student: Good punctuation.
>>Jim: With rubrics that have
been developed by the students,
they're able to look at what they
have done, self evaluate that,
get peer feedback and
teacher feedback.
And what I find is that then
they're internalizing their desire
to improve their work.
>>Do we require, for a four,
that a person have a self
drawn picture or animation?
That's the question.
>>Narrator: When expectations are
clear to both students and teachers,
students develop the ability
to assess their own progress,
a skill essential for
lifelong learning.
>>Jim: Okay, I think we just left
out one important part of multimedia.
When we think of multimedia, we
think of text, graphics and...?
Amanda's got it behind
you maybe there.
>>Sound.
>>Jim: Aha, yes, sound, guys, sound.
One last time, graphics, sounds--
>>Grant: We should assess to say,
"All right, here's what you can do.
Here's what you haven't done.
How can we help you improve?
How does this information, how
does this feedback help you know
and help us know what you
might do to be better?
>>Raymond: It is not the
skill level that changes.
Everybody comes out with
the same skill level.
It's the time it takes that
changes, and some people take two
and a half times as long
to learn as other people.
That's the way people are, that's
the way we are in certain areas.
So when a school finally figures
out that each student must learn
each step before they go to the next,
and everybody will be
competent in each step,
and everybody will make an A, then
we'll change our view of tests.
>>Jim: Wait a minute, Daniel,
you're not answering my question.
You're just jamming for someone.
I don't see the paper in your
hand, I don't see it checked off.
I haven't seen the discussion that
you've had with your partners, okay?
We don't just go and get going
without some planning, thank you.
>>Why don't we just keep
it like this all the time?
>>Let's just keep it like that,
and you wanna change the
colors on the inside.
>>Jim: We do these projects
in the multimedia usually
with at least groups of
two, sometimes three.
So in those groups, there's
a great deal of cooperation
as to what are we going to include?
A great deal of discussion,
and that's learning in itself.
>>Go to the disc.
>>Daniel: Cooperative learning
is a natural living library
that gives children the chance
to master and practice a set
of essential skills for life.
They're skills you could
call emotional intelligence.
They're how you handle your
own emotions and work things
out with people, how you
deal with other kids,
other people in your life.
Things like managing your temper,
you're not going to be able to blow
up and work with a group.
It exerts pressure on you
to learn how to do that.
>>That looks great.
>>Narrator: Cooperative
learning, project based learning
and alternatives to grades to
assess what's been learned?
This doesn't sound like the
schools most of us went to.
As these innovations are introduced,
schools must keep parents
better informed
and encourage greater involvement
in their children's education.
When children see their parents
and teachers working together,
it sends a clear and consistent
message about the value of learning.
At Clear View Charter, parents meet
regularly with teachers and staff
to discuss the school
program in an open forum.
It's an opportunity for teachers to
explain their approaches to learning
to both parents and students.
>>Jim: "You might be asking
yourself the question, "Well,
how do we go about figuring
out, trying to assess whether
or not students are doing any
real learning while their going
through this process-- ?"
>>Education of our
parents is as important
as education of our children.
We're out here trying to let
parents know what we're doing
and why we're doing it; that we're
not giving up on multiplication
and addition and spelling.
We're doing all those things, but
we're just doing it in the context
of using technology to improve
those particular skills.
>>Parent: How is it
different than learning
without multimedia
and without computer?
>>Jim: What I have seen in students
in the last couple of years,
who have now had the
exposure to technology,
that are not only computer,
but videotape technology,
laser disc technology, they
have a very high comfort level
with that technology.
But it also provides them
a feeling of accomplishment
that I have not seen in, say,
traditional forms of education.
>>Juanita: I mean, I've
seen such improvement
in Albert's academic work,
reading comprehension.
Computers, the technology of
computers, has really opened up a lot
for Albert, and I see him wanting
to come to school, bright early,
and leave late, you know.
Always calling me, "Can
I stay a little later?
I need to finish up a
project," you know, and that's--
I'm like, "Wow, yeah, sure."
>>James: The involvement
of the parents and learning
of the child makes a big difference.
It is the interaction between
the child and the parent
that makes the learning meaningful.
Children are almost
programmed to please adults
and their first appreciation of
themselves comes from the feedback
from the important
people around them,
and the most important
people are the parents.
>>Jim: Well, it's to
help you tomorrow.
It's to help you tomorrow when
you're actually directing Steve
on the Microsoft.
Let's take a look.
>>Narrator: It's the day before
Jim Dieckmann's class goes online
with a scientist using
the electron microscope.
But after numerous efforts,
Albert and Charles still
have not caught a wasp.
>>Albert: Do you know
what kind of bug it is?
We don't know where it was.
I just found it on a leaf.
I don't know if it had--
>>Narrator: Even with
cutting edge technology,
learning still has
setback and frustrations.
>>Jim: Now you did
not collect a wasp.
>>Yeah.
>>Did you?
>>But he found one.
>>Okay. Where's that?
>>It's in my garage.
>>Still in your garage,
flying around, right, okay.
It's not going to do
us that much good.
>>Yeah, but we know
where we found it.
>>Right, but what you
want from the microscope,
you want something
that looks like a wasp.
A beetle really doesn't
look like a wasp,
but some of the other things we have.
We have a bee.
>>Yeah, but that's not our thing.
>>I know.
>>It has to be a representative.
>>Jim: Right, now you've
got the picture.
So the representative insect
collected would be a bee, understand?
That way you get a chance to
see what the mouth parts look
like on an animal, an insect
that looks similar to the one
that you had for your project.
So do you think this will give
us additional information or not?
>>Mm-hmm.
>>Probably so...
Albert, could you get up here?
You're kinda hiding down there.
What?
>>I don't care; it's not
a wasp and we need a wasp.
>>Well, you had the opportunity.
>>I still got it, just
have to get it.
>>Well, it's a little late,
if we're going online tomorrow
and it's still flying
around in his garage.
>>Do it another time.
>>Okay, I'm not gonna try to force
you to do anything here, Albert,
but I think if you'll sit down and
think about it, you'll probably come
up with some kind of a conclusion
about what's gonna be best here.
>>Linda: Teachers need to be able
to elicit students' thinking.
They also need to be able
to interpret what they hear students
saying in terms of their learning.
What does it mean about students'
progress when they portray a problem
in a certain way or get stuck
on a particular concept?
And finally, they need to be able
to continually elicit understandings
about how kids are
thinking about their work,
not just whether they
have the right answer.
So this requires a lot of
new tools for teachers.
>>Teacher: And probably
an assassin bug or...
>>Narrator: In San Diego
State University laboratory,
entomologist Doctor Kathy Williams
and Doctor Steve Barlow prepare
for a live fiber optic link into Jim
Dieckmann's classroom miles away.
>>Jim: After them is E8,
E8, was that you, Rodrigo?
Amanda G, Desiree and Emily.
>>Narrator: With an electron
microscope, they'll examine
and discuss the insect specimens
gathered and prepared by Albert,
Charles and their classmates.
>>Jim: All right, Steve,
I think we're ready to go.
Introduce yourselves, boys.
>>Hi, I'm Charles.
>>Hi, I'm Albert.
>>And my name's Patrick.
>>Steve: Okay, so we'll start
with your first sample now?
>>Yeah.
>>Okay, all right, so
this is the head of it.
Now last week we were talking about
looking at mouth parts, correct?
>>All: Yes.
>>Steve: Okay, so here
you can see the two eyes
and in the center is kind of
this long, looks like a nose.
And then down at the
very end of the nose,
we increase the magnification here.
>>What is that?
>>What does it look like?
>>Mouth.
>>Teeth?
>>Kathy: Looks a lot like teeth.
What do you think they use it for?
>>Probably to catch food.
>>Kathy: Well, that's a good
start, that's a good idea.
It's really tiny though,
if you think about it,
so what kind of food
would they get with that,
with little tiny teeth like that?
>>Gnats.
>>Okay, gnats.
>>Tiny flies.
>>Okay, maybe tiny flies.
>>Do you know of the sand bee,
do the mouth parts look
like a bee or a wasp?
>>Kathy: Well, what do you think?
Do you have any ideas about that?
>>I think yeah, because
they're related.
>>That's right, the bees
and the wasps have a lot
of similarities in their mouth parts.
You're getting to be
good entomologists there.
>>Albert: 'Cause me and Charles
are doing a project on wasps.
But we haven't found the wasp,
so we just did the sand
bee and we looked at the--
>>Jim: The contribution of
Doctor Williams was incredible,
because she was giving information,
she was engaging the students
in conversation, she was asking the
students questions, thereby they had
to formulate their
thinking to respond.
And that's what's important, because
we can look at things all day,
but if we don't formulate some
kind of a response to what we see,
we're just taking in information.
We're not synthesizing it in any way.
So that's what I feel the value of
the experts and the interaction,
is what gives the students
the impetus
to internalize some of the learning.
>>John: I think that the
changes we see happening today
in these technology enriched
environments are very important
for two reasons.
First of all, what you find is
that these environments are
encouraging kids to engage constantly
in an active search, and then
taking what they're finding,
combining it with what
other kids have found,
and working kinda collaboratively
on constructing something
with what they find.
So they're learning how to search,
how to challenge what they find
and then how to combine
what they find with others.
Now if there's anything we learn
in kinda corporate America today is
the absolute importance of teamwork.
It's so ironic to me that in the
schools we focus almost exclusively
in the past on the
performance of the individual,
often at the cost of
other individuals.
Whereas when you get into the
workplace, it's really the ability
to productively work with
others that really matters.